[Music]
people must constantly ask for spoilers
because there's so much intrigue about
what's gonna happen on Game of Thrones
people come up to you and they say
please John tell us what's gonna happen
they do they say what's gonna happen and
I always say you don't want to know like
this this can't be the way that you want
to know and when this show has got a
huge budget we've got the best direct
some of the best directors working in TV
some of the best art design people
working in TV do you want to find out
that way the way that they want you to
know yeah beautifully lit beautifully
lit beautifully shot beautifully
directed beautifully acted or do you
want me to tell you now in my little
Manchester accent on a writ on a rainy
Street in London you don't want that if
you want to be told the way they want
the story to be told so I mean I mean
what is gonna happen if I tell them
right they're gonna watch the show and
they're gonna go oh yeah that yeah I
knew that was going to happen
you